ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'on a eu de faits participation aux
élections départementales et régionales
c'est vrai simplement quand on regarde
bien les lecteurs à se déplacer en fer
ont tiré une leçon c'est un petit peu
compliqué je vous rappelle qu'on est
quasiment quatre millions et demi de
gens qui ont participé à la primaire de
droite en 2017 c'est au score nous
n'aurons jamais 4 millions et demi de
participants ça c'est la première chose
et puis une primaire ça coûte cher en
2007 a coûté 8 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui quel est le parti politique
en france est à part la reine qui
pourrait dépenser cette somme là et puis
c'est pas la tradition de droite savez
nous à droite on choisit un chef
on s'engueule en interne et une fois
qu'il ya un chef on est tous derrière il
ya des solutions pour trouver pour faire
émerger le chef il ya des propositions
qui ont été mises sur la table tout
aussi intéressants les sondages etc
mais en l'occurrence si on voulait
vraiment trouvé un ticket il faudrait un
ticket pour la présidentielle moi je
pense que notamment xavier bertrand et
valérie pécresse pourrait se mettre
d'accord pour faire un beau ticket pour
la présidentielle trois présidents mois
premier ministre et sa fermeté et sa
fermerait définitivement le débat et moi
c'est ce que j'appelle je ne partage pas
cet avis puisque en fait les gens qui
n'ont pas été voter aux élections
départementales et régionales sont des
gens qui sont en train de basculer en
dehors du système politique et je pense
que ceux qui ont été voter à la primaire
la maire fois statistiquement on
pourrait faire des sondages mais
statistiquement on était plus verte et
ce sont des gens qui ont plus l'habitude
de participer au scrutin aux différents
scrutins
parce que ce sont des gens qui
s'intéressent beaucoup plus au
fonctionnement de nos institutions en
face les gens moins intéressés sont
peut-être ceux qui plaident aujourd'hui
pour une droite qui retrouvait sa
légitimité à travailler les élus locaux
à travers ce qui reste finalement aux
républicains faute de deux chefs qui se
détache même fait de faute de chefs tout
court c'est à dire au réseau d'élus
locaux
donc il ya 2 2
famille à droite comme celle qui est
peut-être plus j'ai plus gestionnaire et
celle qui est plus axé sur le sur le
régalien et sur le les grandes idées qui
régissent notre vie politique
[Musique]
d'abord elle est compliquée sur des
comparaisons avec quelques années après
lectorat changer les habitudes ont
changé donc une comparaison n'est pas
raison mais je pense qu'on est la
collation après si vous voulez
structurellement un candidat à la
présidentielle qui peut vraiment gagner
présidentielle il élargit le spectre
électorale tout de suite il est besoin
de rassembler les français
il a besoin de rassembler son camp ça je
suis contre la primaire parce que c'est
quoi la primaire a été la clé on se
souvient des perdants et moi du gagnant
et ça crée souvent des à spirit et des
haines et des sentiments de méfiance des
candidats des camps vers l'est vers les
1 et vers les autres pour ça que je
pense que la primaire c'est une machine
à perdre souvenons-nous de benoît hamon
qui a gagné brillamment la primaire du
parti socialiste et qui s'est retrouvé
avec 6% à la présidentielle moi je veux
absolument éviter pour vos quand cette
bérézina qui fermera définitivement les
portes des républicains à la première
division la dernière fois ce n'est pas
la primaire qui a fait perdre la droite
c'est le procès fait aux candidats qui
malgré le toutes les péripéties de cette
campagne a terminé quand même à 20% et
j'ai peur que faute de faute de relais
locaux la campagne et du mal à mobiliser
et les gens vient toujours la même chose
le problème c'est de mobiliser ce sera
le mobile électeurs de droite au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle est
d'ailleurs après au législatif puisqu'on
a vu l'énorme perte de word la
démobilisation suite au deuxième tour de
la présidentielle est celle qui s'en
suivit dans les urnes provoquant une
hécatombe parmi les députés de droite
le candidat orpi verts ils doivent déjà
pouvoir rassembler sa famille politique
au sens très large c'est-à-dire savard
des centristes centre-droit à la droite
plus classique à dire et qu'on connaît
c'est un gars qui est cette capacité
dans un premier temps de venir sa
famille dans un second temps d'élargir
le spectre électorale d'aller chercher
comme l ai dit sarkozy laissez-moi aller
vers tous les français
ça c'est la première qualité après je
dis comme faisons attention parce que
cette primaire pour vous devait
éventuellement pour certains d'entre
nous comment ça va se passer quand on va
l'organiser au mois d'octobre au mois de
novembre alors que nous annonce la
quatrième vague pandémique
voici une vraie question se pose si on a
cinq cent mille participants de 4
millions vous verrez que les détracteurs
les médias etc
seurot arquebouté il faut ce chiffre de
participation et sa n'offrira pas une
dynamique au candidat
bien au contraire je crois que c'est un
profil pour la droite le meilleur
candidat serait l'impro ville assez
similaire t automatique de campagne que
françois fillon avait avait envisagé à
l'époque c'est à dire d'un côté
restaurer le régalien et de l'autre côté
de relancer l'initiative économique mais
c'est cet équilibre entre de cet
équilibre qui pourrait permettre de
lancer un candidat capable d'atteindre